let's go to Andrew from California
Andrew from California welcome what's on
your mind
hi um the first time caller long time
listener thank you uh
kind of nervous but um I'll power
through it yeah you're doing great
I just wanted to discuss with you about
the
when dealing with irrational like Trump
trump supporters yeah
what is the calculus because I've seen a
lot of progressive hosts handle it both
ways where they're like very patient and
uh
charitable in a sense versus like just
steamrolling them and then just hanging
up on them and not letting them talk
like for example for with you you had
that guy who uh you guys were getting
into like the semantics of like Trump
not being allowed with the nuclear codes
yeah and I feel like you took like a
charitable uh approach which I agree I
agreed with you but I felt like you
could have been more charitable
but I I don't know I'm just a schmuck I
don't know uh so listen it depends what
you want to achieve right I mean my
point with that guy that was Bobby Polo
the reason I gave that guy so much time
and so much leeway was he was one of
those guys who showed up in our super
chats during a live stream and said I
want to debate you and you won't debate
me and you won't give me time and blah
blah blah blah and so the point I was
trying to make was I'll gladly give you
time and I'll allow you every
opportunity to make your point and the
guy had 10 minutes and he quite
literally wasn't able to make a single
point and the point of that was less
about telling him he was wrong about
every particular issue he didn't even
bring up an issue that was the funny
thing the guy was desperate to debate
and couldn't actually even hold a
conversation so that was more about like
these people who were big tough guys on
the internet who want to debate then you
give them a chance they make no sense
they might as well be speaking a foreign
language in other situations on somebody
who comes at me with a particular issue
that they're wrong about then it would
be less about being as charitable as
possible and more about showing them
that they're actually wrong on the issue
does that make sense Andrew like it
depends on the situation
yeah I guess it's I don't know I guess
sometimes I I
prefer the more charitable approach I
just feel like maybe then there'd be
more of a chance of
connection but maybe that's just wishful
thinking no I think on balance you're
right it just with that particular guy
you're thinking of it went nowhere
because there was no substance to it you
know we could he wouldn't even
understand what my position was and yet
he still tried to tell me I'm wrong but
it's like dude you don't even understand
what I'm saying how can we go forward
here
I felt like with the nuclear weapons
issue which I think was like the one
that kind of was
ballooned yep I felt like you could have
been a little bit more like
okay when you make a black and white
statement where I don't think Trump
should be around nuclear weapons which
is ridiculous the president must you
know have
you know access to that I just think
that he would be very irresponsible I
didn't feel like you
said it in a way where he was going to
be able to receive that and digest it
and maybe understand that I mean well I
think you're right I don't think he was
going to be able to understand what I
was saying but the extent to which I
just have to keep restating it I think
you know he he had a bunch of time and
he wasn't getting it so it was just time
to move on you know
okay all right one last comment uh bring
back Jimmy from Philly haven't heard
from him for years Andrew it's crazy
I I just miss his voice fair enough
maybe we can find an impersonator all
right Andrew thanks so much for the call
thank you all right there goes Andrew
with a very very powerful declaration